and I'm Lawrence is chief executive of
the Royal Mint and joins me now so Adam
why'd you say this is the most secure
coin in the world well it's got more
security features than we've ever put on
a coin in that comment in a combination
so what you'll immediately notice from a
public perspective is there's 12 sides
there's the latent image on the on the
on the obverse side there's the mils
there's the two materials and then
there's loads of other features that the
cash industry you're looking for like
weights and diameters and measurements
and then there's some special security
features just ask the law enforcement
agencies will know about if we ever need
to get that out stage I'm an interesting
thing feeling it I mean when you first
publish the sort of spec of it a lot of
people comparing it with the old
fluttery bit but it doesn't feel this
harshest that it's around more rounded
edges and so it takes his design from
the old thrupenny bit but one of the
things that came out of the consultation
that we did was to making it smoother so
I can role in inventing mechanisms so I
suppose if you go back many years ago
there wasn't as many vending machines
and parking meters and that so this
needs to be able to roll in all sorts of
environments what about the Queen is she
expressed an opinion on it I served her
picture on the back of it of course well
we don't get an opinion but she has
approved it so I'm sure she looks she
loves it
I think you know if she didn't win you
know I think we might know what about
the old and coins then I mean there's a
big issue with counterfeiting as is is
that why they've had to go essentially I
mean that the primary reason for the new
wing construction decoy is you know the
current one pen coins 34 years old he
just said in your introduction making
technology's moved on a long way there's
becoming more and more susceptible
counterfeiting and the quality of
accountants was very very good so we
needed to introduce something fit for
the 21st century
which is what we've done here with the
most secure coin in the world and the
old pan coins are being phased out from
October the 15th so from that date on
any retailer they're under no obligation
to to accept them that's correct and if
people do happen to have them after
October the 15th take them back to the
bank and show their be able to exchange
them but what I would encourage people
to do is spend them get them back as
quickly as possible because we can
recycle them and that's a really
important thing let's make this
environmentally friendly as well so
you're going to melt them down and what
happens then they get turned into the
new coin to me the new ones Wow what
about I mean you mentioned the the
vending machines and self I mean there
been a few grumbles from some of the
train operating companies and some of
their ticket machines won't take the the
new machines I mean who's this roll out
gone according to plan
I think it's quite fantastic actually I
mean we never expected to get 110
coverage on day one and there's a
logical reason that because some of the
mechanisms aren't capable of handling
the extra coin so they need to choose
the new one versus the old one so some
people always planned to wait till we
get a crossover point where there's more
than 50% in circulation and then switch
off the the old one put the new one in
the fact that we've got 85 to 90%
coverage around the UK I think is
outstanding and I think the industry has
stood behind this program from day one
and said we know why we need to do it
and we're right behind it I think
they've really acted you know they've
done they play their part and in terms
of the phase out of the old coins is
October bringing is that too soon really
a lot of people have these old coins
dust all over the place again the
industry of one of the things they
initially wanted was a shortest code
circulation time as possible because I
have to handle the coins independently
because they're different weights and
different sizes so it's really important
for the economy that we get them back as
quickly as possible we repress this then
we reuse them and we get the new one in
there as quickly you really cook quick
quickly and in terms of people using
cash I'm not reading a report today that
said by 2025 cash will only account for
about a quarter of all transactions it's
this likely to be the last ever pound
coin produced oh I wouldn't I wouldn't
know about that I mean I think the death
of cash has long been predicted but you
know I don't see it easing off anytime
soon there's lots of predictions about
2025 or whatever it is I think it's a
long way beyond that
and briefly it is a very pretty coin
this and as you say most the curve it's
kind of the world you make coins for all
over the rest of the world if you got
other people beating a path to door now
saying : we want something similar we do
actually yeah it's I mean it's a really
interesting dilemma because this is
great technology again developed in the
UK and we can sold all over the world so
we'll be exporting this new technology
everywhere nice to have a nice export
story on wish to finish Allen Lawrence
thanks are joining me